[Music]
in Canadian criminal news no such I
don't believe it
the submitted by whatever this is big
wibbels do you know what you just said
big eggs testicle this is what she said
literally bad balls oh shoot okay
submitted my big balls
a man carjacks a woman in the most
Canadian way possible get out your car
please just with maple syrup instead
sorry yeah sorry sorry sorry
Canada we really do love you Canada's
great that's like 1915 I want to go
there yeah fifties American it's like
1950s America colder yeah so this takes
place in Alberta what's before global
warning and so this woman she was on her
way to work she was driving near this
Airport when she came across the
collision between a pickup truck and a
school bus
oh look like this oh my god it's cool
yeah no one's hurt wait on a date
alright moose food when she approached
the accident she saw that there was this
man standing outside and then she was
like asking him like hey you know are
you okay or anything and he and so like
she kind of had his face turned away
from her he didn't respond to her so
that she asked again and then that's
when he turned further and she saw he
had a bandana over his face oh snap wait
how does she not recognize that was he
blood or Chris no no blood definitely
blood yeah they go white bandanas for
the snow yeah it's no side so she said
that he didn't see anything that he just
kind of groaned and struck started
walking toward her car that's mine now
so then she was like what are you doing
and then that she started to run back to
her car so then he started running and
then he pulled out a gun Association so
she stopped she put her hands up and she
was like it's yours and then the man
asked if he so he handed up asking a few
questions he was like he do you have any
children in the back
she's like no when's your last oil
change you
I'll get it done I'll get it inspected
I'll return it full-time premium I'll
get your oil she's gonna need your whip
so then so then that's when he asked her
like do you need anything from your cart
so she was like well
oh she was he was like and he's like the
whole thing please is so nice do we need
your phone and she was like yes if
you're gonna leave me in negative 20
degrees Celsius ah damn [ __ ] your
[ __ ] attitude do you need your
[ __ ] [ __ ] like how she still has sass
even though she had a gun to her face
dude well [ __ ] do you think he's fine I
could call for help in the tundra so
then he gave her her phone her purse and
her lunch bag dudes all right and then
he said sorry sorry sorry sorry and then
took her 2012 silver Mitsubishi
Outlander you know that in Canada like
if you get in our car wreck nice good
work dude
and he drop it off at her house cleaned
it and detailed it out weeks later man
did he crash a stolen car and then he
stole her correctly so this has been a
string of events
oh so the week earlier there were two
men in a stolen Ford FP trusted partner
who broke into a tire shop and then they
used the truck to ram through the
service bay door where they stole
another truck it's not very well thought
out it's the worst Grand Theft Auto game
I know
he's stealing card after card at the
card a grand theft auto Alberta
worse yet another guy there's no one
there yeah just snow police later found
the f350 and it was about a hundred
kilometres north of where the Miocene
takasu people speak English today a
distance no one knows in a temperature
we can't comprehend
during the rest of the world knows yeah
that's what I'm saying speak American
what's the kilometres figure it up as
soon as I hear that I'm like all this
yellow meters were pretty heavy okay it
was killing me two pounds how many
kilometres they broke into a gas station
five K's like 3.1 only drug dealers in
America know that way hey joven to this
other building why did he keep running
into buildings why [ __ ] outside I bet
you it's because they kept your light
and on the road they kept sliding cuz
it's like ice all over I would crack the
[ __ ] up if they ran into the building
and it just walked out with the door
open because I looked out the door
I would laugh my ass off trying to steal
gas other gas station one of those
things of like traveling and like going
to other countries like like Scotland or
Iceland it always [ __ ] me up cuz if you
stop and get gas like I'm sitting there
and I'm trying to like running my credit
card and get gas and like walk inside
I'm like look it won't take my card yeah
I just want to I want to fill a car all
the way up yeah fill it up and then come
pay us why you're down there just like
why why would you pay first I don't like
America I'm trashed you don't know me
but I'm trashed right I'll [ __ ] leave
with this to teach you a lesson
her generosity
you stupid idiot - I think it's organ
but they have gas stations we're like do
they serve your car yeah the whole state
yeah it was like that's why it says self
yeah we got that here we're all back in
the day we had it like all over like in
the 60s and then they got rid of that
Jersey and jewelry's still full service
the whole state in New Jersey she's
super [ __ ] annoying like at 72nd
shell stations where you go up and it's
they don't they what comes for you they
actually told me once cuz I parked in
one by accident and then we're like oh
you know that's not self-serving
whatever I was like oh my bad homes you
could pull up and you could be like yes
sir right away sir and then they fill it
up and we're gonna get I don't think
some stereotype runs up just some guy
hey how much do you tip a couple dollars
do you tip for that yeah [ __ ] that you
could do yourself [ __ ] blue yeah yeah
no it's not [ __ ] you can do yourself
you're not allowed Oh even if anyone
does something for you usually
especially if they have to touch you
somewhere at chip
well the alternate [ __ ] you is to just
own an electric vehicle there's three
people in that Club right there's like
only six places that you can fill it up
Oh have you heard of Tesla I'm off heard
of the company maker pay stations near
work really be stuck there's like nine
[ __ ] hours oh I'm gonna take the
charge of Tesla from from Juna you're
not from here in town yeah I live in
Louisiana Louisiana
I'm sorry because that's right that's
right
is it the main studio bush though what's
the main city of religion oh good where
they got the French Quarter new world
New Orleans
I want to go Cafe Du Monde do me a favor
and don't cuz I want to eat a bun bun
yay there's tons of place in that
vignette it's just gotta name fried
bread and powdered sugar just go have a
sofa peel Disneyland has some you know
what write me when I went to café du
monde and I was like I feel like I had
this at the other place that was the
same [ __ ] thing
you're not wrong it's a chain they have
multiple yeah they have them an airport
there's quite a lot of places that make
beignets just as good as that plum or
better as people call it yeah because
when I went there and we waited to get
the [ __ ] and I was like we just had a
vignette it's just you the homies own a
doughnut shop district doughnuts in New
Orleans and there shit's way better than
Cafe Du Monde Keva du monde is burning
out seven million beignets a day and
shitty coffee god damn it's just a war
place in my heart because that's what
the Vietnamese use for their espresso
they use what that orange can they use
that orange can they use Cafe Du Monde
cousin yeah with chicory yeah they use
chicory coffee come on and then
condensed milk I had my mind blown by an
Asian thing a couple months ago
please Vietnamese coffee bar yeah oh
yeah it's like our Hooters yeah yeah
hundred girls I just cruise around
lingerie now did you just play mahjong
you talk about the copy the cat babe
Orange County that's awesome I went to
wound up in NorCal
oh I guess it's spreading so whatever it
was like a place where dude they were
like sports on TV and like good guys are
smoking cigarettes inside and playing
card games and like girls
yeah and girls were walking around
they're not hostess bar there's just
it's like a Hooters right where they're
just like yeah but it was like big fake
tits blonde here well it's almost like
borderline stripper girls that aren't
stripping their clothes right I heard
that place gets lit at night though it's
half naked [ __ ] and coffee yes yes
this bar that's different that's because
girls sit with you and like hang out and
drink with you and they talk and
whatever
damn guys are so sad yeah not
complicated creatures by the way because
since the ving amis cafes don't they sit
with the guys - oh really sure they just
so you don't have to because the hostess
is getting paid to entertain and sit and
talk and hang out all they do is serve
drinks but if it just so happens that
there's a group of young guys and then
or dare a friend of a friend right
they're cool
they would sit there and hang out which
you can talk to you but they're not
permitted that they don't have to they
look real dead behind the others Lemos
yeah this was up in here in Orange
County yeah I went to when it started
here yes he and his parents just to go
see what it was like his parents are
freaks it's pretty it's pretty it's
pretty dirty though I would say well
some a lot of places some of them not so
much it had the right grime I liked it
yeah give it a 4 out of 5 stars would go
back on Yelp yeah yeah but they make you
buy drinks before you sit down though
yeah
can you request more from these ladies
or is thank you mean like maybe under
the table like they get paid well though
they get like 30 bucks an hour or
something on this channel Vietnamese
coffee bars yeah I'll see you okay
never heard of late to the show yeah
yeah it's pretty cool anyway we're
talking about this oldest Canadian
comedian dude hot so they're still
looking these gentlemen they did arrest
one man he crashed it and found another
car it's like someone's stealing your
wallet and be like here's your ID and
credit cards like these aren't any good
to me are you cancel really he just gave
you your good stuff no so yeah someone
stole my wallet and my phone we left the
car unlocked and I grabbed them to do
breaking oh yeah and my grandpa's been
arrested they weren't in a hurry
yeah so then and they went in they stole
everything but then they put all of our
credit cards and like important stuff
they just take the cash cuz this isn't
TJ yeah and then they
lesson in the plastic bag and returned
it to the church where we held service
for my crown that's not bad that's not
bad at all
AHS an inside job exactly she and it's
still nice of them because it kind of
took everything else listen are you
serious I never have enough cash in my
wallet for that to be the pain in the
ass it's the day that you cost me of now
I have to go to the [ __ ] movie and
it's even worse when you're out of the
country because how do you get back into
the country without your passport
without haven't you seen [ __ ] born
into East LA I don't think it was the
name of that but it was it was [ __ ]
what's his name Cheech and Chong Cheech
and Chong
they [ __ ] go across the border they
can't come back to the US but they were
born into East LA but but they were like
you're emigrant you can't really no no
listen I lost my passport and all that
stuff they're like shut up and he
couldn't come back to the Americas so he
had to come sneak into America there's a
bullet don't remember that [ __ ] oh yeah
I'm born in an East LA
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]